I had a really good day recently.
Is it an interesting story?
This is the story of how I almost
threw up in front of David Mitchell.
Sounds interesting.
Sounds like it's gonna be interesting.
Probably would be more interesting if
I actually threw up in front of David Mitchell.
I'm very please that
that didn't happen, though.
I guess, for me, it's one
of those momemnts
that tests whether or not I'm
making decisions in my life
because I want to or because I think
that they will make good videos,
and in this case, I thought,
"You know what? I'm gonna
take one for the team and uhh--"
No, I'm gonna take one
for me, not for the team.
Screw the team.
So I mean the whole story basically is
I went on a walk with David Mitchell.
He's a comedian.
He's a nice guy as well.
My friend, Ken,
introduced me to him.
He said, "Oh, I'm going on a walking tour
of London with David Mitchell--"
I don't know why
he speaks like that.
He doesn't speak like that.
He's American.
He speaks like this... Now I have
to do a good impression of him.
(ATTEMTED AMERICAN ACCTENT)
"Charlie, I'm going on a walking tour
of London, the City of London."
He does actually sound quite like that.
I'm pretty impressed.
(ATTEMTED AMERICAN ACCTENT)
I'm going on a walking tour of
the City of London
with David Mitchell,
which you're welcome to come
along to if you do so desire.
Paraphrasing, obivously.
A part of me was like, "Ahh, I don't know.
I don't want to be mooching off your friendship
'cause Ken knows quite a lot of cool
people, but I, you know, I gave in.
I thought, "Yes, I will come."
And he was very nice about it,
but the problem I have is
I have a very weak stomach,
a very bad digestive system.
Just the act of eating and walking
makes me want to throw up.
I had lunch with Ken, went
on a walking tour of London
with Ken and David Mitchell, spent
the whole thing wanting to throw up,
we went to a pub afterwards.
David offered to buy me a
drink at the pub and I said,
"Can I have a water
'cause I feel quite ill."
And he said,"Oh I didn't
know you were feeling ill."
I made him feel bad about
the fact that I was feeling ill
becasue I didn't tell him 'casue
I was too embarrassed.
And then they both went
to go and sit down.
And I was like, "Yep, I'm
gonna go to the toilet now."
I sat on the toilet
for a little while.
I got off the toilet
and I threw up into it.
I looked at myself
in the mirror.
I looked like someone who had
just thrown up, but I thought,
"Well, that's just who I am today.
I'm the boy who threw up."
And when, you know, I went to say
hello to them I you know, I said,
"Yes, I feel a lot better now."
I didn't way "Hey guys,
I just threw up!"
I just let them fill in
the gaps themselves.
This is how they find out.
David, now you
know as well.
I almost threw up on you.
I was very, very close, but I held
it in, and aren't I a great guy,
and to proove this whole story,
here's a photo of me with David Mitchell
in a pub with lots of
ties on the celing.
I didn't even notice the
ties until I saw that photo.
No idea what the
hell that is.
If you want to
retrace the steps,
it was a pub called The Ship or
maybe just Ship? Ship the Pub.
Go there and imagine-- maybe
I should do like an audio tour guide
so you can do the same
walking tour that we did
but with my internal monologue
going on and on about
"Oh my God, I feel so sick,"
and I frequently sat--
It was a great tour.
He's a very interseting man.
He taught me a lot.
And um...yeah.
Anictote.
You're welcome.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool
CHARLIE VOICE: By the way,
just in case you missed it.
Ahh, it's one of these, isn't it?
Good. Go and do it 'casue, you know,
not many people saw this,
so that's the way of
it sometimes, isn't it?
It's the trailer for
my new short film.
Click on the thing or don't.
I mean I'd like it if you did 'cause
I'm proud of it, but um...yeah.
Alright, that's that done.